[Music]
not so neighborly news Oh
neighbors submitted by canned chicken
yeah is that real yeah
hey you think sell that a Costco and
baking an entire chicken they do know I
thought was like chopped up chicken
breasts yeah but they I've seen an
entire chicken how would you how would
you eat that
dude that chopped up chicken in the can
though it tastes like gasoline I don't
like you made one that was really good
you put like peas and carrots and
mayonnaise in it and you mix it all up
yeah you used to eat that I thought it
was nastiest saltiest Bart takes after
his dad where once he likes it once he's
like [ __ ] it I'm gonna buy enough for
the rest of the year oh yeah it's
disgusting and I'm like I'm not gonna
eat this [ __ ] sodium can but he would
like it so I'm like borrow while you're
here well you made a yummy it's the same
[ __ ] every day for 365 it's like don't
you remember that delicious bill you
maybe it was trash and I can't believe
you ate [ __ ] I guess if you like it I'll
bake it you didn't notice I made
everyone else pissed at you has to be
built around an affordable housing
community because the neighbors don't
want them there so they built a wall
around the project somebody feel bad
about their living situation that's
[ __ ] funny not only are they poor
they have to wake up to this huge
walkers rich people horse how are their
rich people next to the projects this
isn't the state I'm in Florida that's so
bad because I would have been on the
side where the wall was built around me
like everybody just like I'm already
poor well you have to kick me while I'm
down dude yeah so Habitat for Humanity
will be building this community of
affordable homes and it'll
116 new homes but the neighborhoods like
around her like the neighbors around
they just kept trying to block it they
were just like no we don't want more
affordable housing because they already
have a whole community nearby so this
would be like the like the second
community in that same area and they're
trying to block it and then finally they
came with to an agreement where if they
build two concrete walls and a
chain-link fence on the other side then
that's how they'll accept that community
you build there this is the proposal
it's nice yeah and then there's like a
lot of vegetation here is the long yeah
where would the wall be this is the
property this is where the concrete wall
would be and this is the chain-link
fence yeah this thing's counterintuitive
because if I'm just driving through that
neighborhood that wall would make me
more creeped out than like seeing these
nice cute little houses yeah I guess
they're trying to keep the people out
yeah they partner with projects comes
drugs and stuff like I will say this
though if you know just from somebody
who grew up very very [ __ ] poor we
were huh [ __ ] hoodlums though you
know I mean like we would straight-up
trash some of the nicer areas like
that's not even like that's not even
something that's like oh the same [ __ ]
yeah it's not like something that there
people are people are like oh well
you're just saying that every no we're
not saying everybody's like that but
there were people like me when I was
younger are there bad people that would
go there we would rob those homes not me
but I knew people that would rob those
homes [ __ ] do all that [ __ ] our house
would get [ __ ] there was always like
our neighbours trying to come in going
into our garage taking our [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] time yeah it was work this is
happening right now in LA like um I live
in Beverly Hills but I don't live in the
nine oh two one oh zip code okay I live
on my foot poor people side there's like
an invisible wall between 90210 and then
the others of her but essentially like
you know how the purple line is trying
to go into Beverly Hills literally
Beverly Hills High School they had an
organized walkout because we don't want
the well I don't want to say we I just
lived there they don't want the purple
line coming into Beverly Hills because
there's gonna be bus stops cause I still
had a walkout yeah
they had porta-potties at the walk out
location from the high schooler's it was
organized they had organized buses to
take them to the location and I was like
this is the privileged [ __ ] yeah that's
a very luxurious protest yeah very look
that porta-potties know the fancy
porta-potties that work floors and
everything that's what they do on red
ale like during their holiday sir Phil's
coffee there too during the contest if
poor people come we're going to walk out
yeah so they're protesting against the
poor people come on they're saying that
like they want the tunnel to go under
the h HS but then they're saying that
that could like release some oils blow
up the school but then like it's been
approved about it won't blow up this
school but then like people are saying
that they're using that as a cover like
save our students we don't want them to
blow up but it's really like most people
don't want it to come into every house
yeah I didn't it makes sense though like
so uh there's this little city in the
desert called Palmdale and when that
place was developing a lot of people
from the ghettos of South Bay like
Compton or whatever they would move out
there because to start a new life so
there'll be all these brand new tract
homes right and then my friends family
moved out there but it's it's literally
the ghetto in nice new tract homes
that's so true that happened in Apple
Valley to my she moved out there cuz
like my cousin was a hoodlum but then
they all moved over there so you just
started with new kings over there
exactly in less than five years the
whole ladies got [ __ ] over yeah like
how they save you know like it's like if
you don't change the mentality if you're
used to what your how your living
standards are then you're just gonna
[ __ ] up nice places yeah affordable
housing means projects too by the way in
case you didn't know that's that's what
it basically but there is study though
if you take someone out of a bad trashy
area and then you put them in a nice
area they start wanting to change but it
can't be groups and drugs and people it
has to be like one poor family that
moves into a middle-class or upper-class
like neighborhood and then they want to
up their standards in life but then if
it's a whole entire community just like
up leaving and then they just thought to
come in and drawers yeah they maintained
that
mentality that ghetto mentality they
just they continue it it's like the
language when like people come and they
go to a Korean area and they just came
from Korea they never really learned
English even though other people they're
like in like more Americanized they
learn English and they're moving so I
guess it's like that is the wall is just
it's so like the meaning it is it's like
hey here's a reminder that you're
[ __ ] broke yeah
sick curiosity how tall is the law oh
that's tall too that's not even like a
you know if you have a house then the
window is like you just see you wall oh
yeah that's true
that sucks man but we think I try to
make it nicer and then cover it with the
you know those Bush yeah this road stuff
I like the vines or something and then
like what if they're like daddy why is
there a wall but so sad I wonder if
there's a way where cuz we're dead no
son we live in the ghetto I wish there
was a way to create like neighborhoods
that were a little more sporadic like it
in but closer in range with with income
so like you can't have extremely rich
and you can't have extremely poor
but then you can grab all the super poor
people that's in like one city or
whatever and then you can like disperse
them into like these other neighborhoods
like nicer neighborhoods that are like
middle-class or something yeah yeah yeah
and then then they can kind of help out
in focus and then but yeah it doesn't
work like that but like how would you
feel like if you guys just bought like
an awesome house put a bunch of money
into it and then this came around and
now your house price is like your values
good I see the other side too you know
what I mean like I get it like that like
much for example like the neighborhood
that my parents live in right now a lot
of like lower-income people started
coming in and it's just getting a little
a little a little ghetto you know what I
mean I mean doesn't bother me because I
grew up there so it's not that big of an
issue but I could see with people who
owned these properties and the
properties going down like in the [ __ ]
there's like cars on the [ __ ] lawn
now but I mean even ghetto people don't
want to be ghetto you know what I mean
like when they get a little bit of money
they upgrade in life they want to get
the hell out they don't want to stay in
their community well and then if what if
they get like they get out of the hood
and then they buy a nice house and in
the hood comes back to them buy this
should happen yeah you know don't like I
would be pissed oh yeah I'll be like
what the [ __ ] I saved up all this money
went to school did everything right and
then [ __ ] this comes to me ya know what
a wall make you feel better no I'd want
to sell my house and leave like I don't
want to be near cheap housing you know I
mean like it's because my investment
went down it's like well I you know I
saved up to buy this house and then all
of a sudden the [ __ ] depreciation
value say well what the [ __ ] I just got
[ __ ] over yeah yeah yeah not because
really like the danger or anything like
that it's more because of that like the
value it's like yeah [ __ ] I paid so much
for it so they're saying that they're
gonna start construction in about three
years
also like neighbors that were
interviewed and they're saying like well
I'm not gonna judge I'm just glad that
they're gonna have a wall for the other
people who feel like their privacy is
getting invaded so that seems to be the
main concern is the privacy being
invaded cuz we're in California too and
there's not as much space as that that
looks like a lot of [ __ ] space and
that wall looks like a lot of distance
from the homes but for us it's like word
we're like right smack yeah like you
open up a [ __ ] door like this and
then there's just nothing but wall two
feet away and I'll be real with you too
if I'm [ __ ] porous [ __ ] I get to
live in a big-ass house because of
government assistance I don't think I
give a [ __ ] about a wall ya know that
[ __ ] wall give a [ __ ] oh there's like
these homes like out of Sacramento -
they're like those cookie cutter homes
they left [ __ ] like six bedroom homes
they're huge and they're paying like
[ __ ] 300 bucks a month for it what
yeah yeah cuz they're all government
assisted Wow yeah we we do have
neighborhoods here we're like just two
block away it's like all these expensive
homes and in a block away it's kind of
like right around the corner it's like
four homes and [ __ ]
so it's not that different yeah and
there'll be people like in the
neighborhood like I knew like people
that would come in to our store you know
we talked I chop it up with them I grew
up with them and there's like these
young girls that would pop out kids just
so they could get like of urban
assistance like that's just real [ __ ]
yeah those are all my neighbors dude
yeah that's all that [ __ ] pop out like
like cuz the more kids you have the more
money they would hope that the kid
had learning disabilities that they
could get even more yeah I mean what
kind of Lies do these kids
horrible horrible life completely
horrible they were on their own
like with just in diapers walking the
neighborhood bare for lying really yeah
and this is like some [ __ ] to like when
I was younger to I'm like oh that's dope
I didn't know what that meant I never
thought that was dope I'm like damn it I
thought it was cool I was like oh that
makes sense you're gonna you know live
in a dope house because if there's that
bad as an adult you're like oh what the
[ __ ] am I thinking yeah like my friends
had section 8 housing exactly and I was
like what like the government helps you
pay for it even a better house that's so
cool yeah I didn't know
[Music]